Hey, babe
What
um
Nothing, how was um, just asking. How are you?
You haven't asked me that in five years I remember because that was around the time. I started taking father than this seriously, yeah
That's so not cool
That makes me wonder. Do you think maybe we just like stop trying a little bit?
What do you mean?
well...
Well what?
You're wearing Crocs with socks
so are you
cause they're flats
Oh, I got some bad news for you, babe
Mm. I
Feel like maybe we just stopped trying, maybe we need to connect a little bit. I stage houses for my job
I make all things look new and shiny, maybe that's what we need in a relationship
Sounds expensive
Yeah, yeah, maybe a little bit, but do you remember? How we used to dress up?
How we used to go out on sexy date
So it's probably not surprising that females have a more active system for emotional memory
Which means we recall feelings not just facts something that's harder for a man to do
This is why it seems like women can access visceral memories with search engine like speed
After years of research we discovered the male and female brain is wired very differently to him
I'm basically a blow-up. Doll. Oh my god. That is what you look like
Thank you. Well. You know that grooming releases endorphins in the female brain let's not forget the christmas present I gave you
like the Brazilian straightening. I like my hair it looked like those dudes from the Dukes of Hazzard
I don''t even know who that is
I'm a it was my American accent. You mean, you don't know the Dukes of Hazzard?
The area responsible for defending your turf is larger in the male brain. I'm a physical marvel
Oh, try me throw something I mean anything okay?
So I wasn't ready for that
Women are also more likely to recognize flaws the hell you're wearing I threw that thing out like three years ago
I take out the trash so now
it's back live in effect
(Women want to be MMA fighters but they still want us to hold the door open for 'em)
These gender roles they've been in us for 20,000 years
You like this look? how's it feel to be dating a magician?
Relationships take work want me to work two jobs. Why don't we take the drug morally?
It's not the one to make you eat people's faces
Shall we turn some music on?
(crickets) There's no music on?
Three let go one two, three ... ah, you son of a
Knowing your brain makes life so much easier even though people have been complicated
Nobody can deny our ability to get back up. Yeah. Yeah, yeah
You just said yet nine times yeah
Can I tell you something? Yeah sure I think you're a physical marvel I?
See and she thought jelly jellies not really something you catch jellies some bread eat. Yeah. Yeah, you ready
Those were two peppers in a bag he's like kitchen nunchucks